Film Courage: What are some of the most important
questions you are asking yourself when you
are developing a story idea?
Jeffrey Reddick, Screenwriter: I think who
my audience is.
Is the story interesting enough?
Usually for my horror stuff, is there enough
stuff here to care about the characters, but
are we coming up with enough scares that we
haven’t seen before?
Those are the kind of things I ask myself.
It’s interesting because I love doing it
and I’ve done it for so long and it’s
not easy work at all because people don’t
understand especially when you are threading
a script together and dissecting it and making
sure everything kind of lines up and pieces
together, you want to put your best foot forward.
But you also realize that once you sell and
it’s out of your hands, a lot of that stuff
just goes out of the window.
So that’s why I’m not as harsh when I
see a movie.
I reserve judgment on the writer until I read
the actual screenplay because you just never
know what changes from page to screen.
But for me it’s usually (because it’s
always horror), also do I think this is going
to strike a chord with people.
FINAL DESTINATION deals with death which is
kind of a universal fear which will reach
a wide audience (I’m not going to lie about
that).
You want to hit as many people as you can
with your concept.
That’s what I love about the horror genre.
I think the fears that we have are a universal
fear that aren’t regulated to one region
or one part of the world.
I think we all kind of have the same fears
deep down so I think you can kind of tackle
a whole bunch of different kinds of stories
and still have it play well all around the
world.
Film Courage: I like how you use the analogy
of it’s like knitting.
And if you, let’s say you are knitting or
crocheting something and you pull one little
string here, that it can really effect the
whole sweater or whatever?
Jeffrey Reddick: Yeah and a lot of people
don’t realize that especially when they
give you notes…like I know one time I had
a project where the producers came in and
they were like “We think he’s full of
sh*t but we’re going to give him a shot
at directing,” because he directed some
things before.
But his pitch…he kind of came in…he had
this opening scene because this whole movie
built up around this plot twist about these
characters not knowing each other and his
opening scene was basically it was very clear
that these characters knew each other.
And in my first meeting with him I was trying
to be very diplomatic.
I was like “How do you propose we do that
opening scene so we don’t spoil the fact
that they know each other because that was
kind of the whole twist of the script and
it was one of those “Well, you’re the
writer.
You figure it out.”
It’s kind of like, I will spoil the end
of USUAL SUSPECTS if you haven’t seen it.
But that’s like going pretend Kevin Spacey
didn’t make it all up and Keyser Söze is
a real person.
But you are like “The whole point of the
movie is…”
Or like the end of the SIXTH SENSE, pretend
Bruce Willis like is a real person and not
a…But when they come to do something like
that, they obviously don’t understand, you
are taking the core of what makes this movie
like the core mystery and you are giving it
away at the beginning and so it’s going
to change the whole movie.
And you’re like “Aahh, you’ll figure
it out.”
So it shows a certain level of understanding
of how much thought you do need to put into
a good screenplay.